NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
Who's ready to unleash
your inner bear?
The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for...
We will take you from zero
to kitchen hero.
...Or they'll walk away
with nothing.
What does it cost?
$39.99.
Guys, I love the product.
I hate the price.
You sharks might be thinking
you've seen this before.
You sharks haven't.
Talk is cheap.
Money talks.
Here's where I think
you're going with that.
You know where I'm going
with it.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
This year, we're looking
to do $5 million.
Tell me the projection
for the next six months.
We'll do about $10 million
in sales.
Ooh.
Wow.
None of you sound that smart.
Who said, "I have an idea"?
He did.
I knew it, and you're
the best-looking one, too.
NARRATOR: ...They're ready
to invest using their own money.
I don't do good deals.
I do great deals.
[ laughs ]
I'll give you $50,000
for 10%.
I thought
you were out.
Shut up.
Don't tell me to shut up.
NARRATOR: And they're
willing to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'll give you $100,000
at 20%.
My offer's
a better offer.
I wouldn't listen.
What do
you guys think?
Guys, if you listen
to this offer,
there's
an expiration date.
I guarantee you my offer's
better than that.
Appreciate the offer.
We do.
I scooped you.
I'm really pissed,
Lori.
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban --
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
are entrepreneurs
from Park City, Utah,
with a healthier version
of a favorite breakfast treat.
Hey, sharks.
I'm Joel Clark.
And I'm
Cameron Smith.
Our product
is Kodiak Cakes.
We're here seeking
$500,000
in exchange for 10%
of our business.
Kodiak Cakes is
a flapjack-and-waffle mix.
It's unique because it's made
with 100% whole grains,
has no added fats
or sugars,
and all you have to do
to make it is add water.
But most importantly,
it tastes amazing.
It really does.
And when I was
8 years old,
I went around
the neighborhood
and sold pancake mixes
like these out of a red wagon.
[ laughter ]
my mom had always wanted
to sell her whole-wheat
pancake recipe as a mix,
so we decided
to give it a try.
We're determined
to build Kodiak Cakes
into a nationally
recognized brand.
We believe
we have great products,
and we have
a proven track record.
Now, who's ready
to unleash your inner bear
and start flipping
flapjacks with us?
[ roars ]
aah!
So, we're gonna give you guys
a sample to try.
All right.
We've got
our berry syrup here.
Thank you.
You're so polite.
What kind of berries?
Mountain berries,
so it has a mix of berries.
There's about five different
berries in there.
Thank you.
Uh-huh.
Is this your product, too,
the berry syrup?
It is. Yeah. We have a line
of fruit syrups, as well.
Wow, they're very good.
Oh, thank you.
The berry syrup's
amazing.
really good.
That's good, isn't it?
I'm glad you like that.
I don't know. I love it.
I'd eat more.
Every day, we get letters
in to our website saying,
"hey, that is the best
pancake mix I have ever tried."
what's your track record
that's so proven?
Yeah, so,
we've actually been able
to get this product
into target stores nationwide.
Target?
Come on.
The first order to target
was about a $260,000 order.
That's a sizable order.
Good for you.
It was a huge order.
In a year,
how much more have you sold
since the first
$260,000?
So, this year, we'll do
around $1 million at target.
Wow.
We have an everyday
low price with target,
but we still have
a 45% margin on that price.
They rolled it out into over
1,600 target stores nationwide.
Are they reordering?
They are.
That's why we came here,
'cause we need the money now
to grow more so we can launch
some innovative products.
But why not just borrow money
against your receivables?
Right.
Why not roll over the money
that you're bringing in
and not even have to take out
any type of loan?
Yeah, we could grow
the pancake mix like we are,
but we're ready to explode
this business now.
How much you gonna sell?
So, this year, we're looking
to do $5 million.
And last year,
we did $2.5 million,
so we're looking
to double.
CORCORAN: And all
in pancake mix?
CLARK:
It's about 75% pancake mix,
and then the syrups
are about 22%,
and then we have
a couple of other products.
Joel, let's be realistic.
Yeah.
This is a complete commodity.
There's nothing
proprietary about it.
What you have here
is a brand you're building.
Ultimately,
if the brand becomes big enough,
we hope that
a major takes it out
because
it's starting to itch
and steal some
of their shelf space.
Sure.
Yeah.
You're not there yet,
because $5 million in
this category is not that much.
Right.
But it's
an interesting beginning.
So let's just focus on what
you've asked for this company.
You're telling me
you want $500,000 for 10%.
That imputes
a value of $5 million.
Yeah.
You know
you're not worth that.
Well, we think
we are.
You're trying to sell it to me
at 10 times your pretax profits.
Never.
What we've found is that
people are willing to pay
for that whole-grain,
healthy breakfast product.
A lot of those other
white-flour, white-mix
pancake mixes out there,
those are commodities.
But those guys, without
mentioning their brand --
no.
famous aunt involved,
here.
[ laughter ]
She leads the share
in this market.
So you're taking share
away from her,
yeah.
And I would think
that she's significantly lower
in price right now.
She is.
How much lower?
Up to 50%.
You think that
the average mom out there
is gonna walk
into a store
and pay twice as much
for a premium product.
They are, though.
Our sales are really,
really increasing.
In the last three years,
we've grown at 40% to 50%,
year on year.
Our cost is $1.65,
and our selling price
is an average of $3.02.
I think your packaging,
though, I just have to say,
I think
it's interesting.
It makes you think,
"oh, that seems like outdoor,
camping, you know, griddle."
yeah.
People love
this brand.
They don't know the brand.
A mom doesn't walk
into target and say,
"Oh, it's
the Kodiak Cakes guys."
The thousand-pound bear
in the room --
not this one.
this is a ratty little thing.
[ laughter ]
The big problem is,
you've got two monster
competitors in this space.
Yeah.
You have to put in the risk
when you value the business,
because if they want
your shelf space at target,
they can come
and take it from you.
No, because target --
yes, they can.
Here's why
you're wrong, Kevin.
No, I'm not wrong.
Not on a commodity.
I'm never wrong, Mark,
by the way.
Because target, Costco,
they have to have competition
for the big brands.
They have to have
some leverage.
It doesn't mean they have
to let them be profitable.
They can make these guys stay
in there with listing fees
till the cows come home.
So, they put them out
of business, and then
who takes their place?
There always has to be a
second product. There always
has to be a third product,
because otherwise, they're not
gonna keep the big guys honest.
no. they leave them on life
support with crappy margins.
We can sell half as much
as the famous aunt in a store --
half -- and still generate
a higher margin,
more revenue
for the store.
HERJAVEC: Joel, you're making
half a million dollars a year.
That's fantastic.
I haven't heard any reason
why you need $500,000.
So, what
we want to do is
we want to spend a huge chunk
of that on slotting fees.
That's like buying your way
into the store...
Oh!
Oh.
Which we generate a return
on in 10 to 20 weeks.
Explain to everybody
what a slotting fee is.
You're buying
shelf space.
Yeah. You're paying an up-front
fee to get your shelf space.
Have you done that
before?
We have done that for 17 years,
and we get a return on it.
I have to defend you,
because there's a million people
that would want to pay
the same slotting fee,
so they picked you.
and you made it work.
He did it. He got
to target without it.
Let's say I give you
$500,000, all right?
How do I get my money back,
and when?
We're gonna build this thing
to $20 million in four years.
How much can you sell
a $20 million commodity
pancake business for?
Well, this is not a
commodity pancake business.
This is a branded
pancake business.
Let's not argue
about that.
Tell me how much
you're planning to sell it for.
Well, at that point,
we're gonna go for one to
one and a half times revenue.
I believe we'll get
one and a half times,
so we'll go
for $30 million.
Food companies --
I'm sorry --
just don't trade
for 10 times cash flow.
They do -- 8 to 10 times.
Our research shows that.
We've talked
to investment bankers.
We're talking to people
all the time.
I love it
when people tell you that,
but they never write a check
for you.
I'm the only disciplined,
rational investor up here.
Everybody else gets
emotionally involved,
[ laughter ]
all right? not me.
All right, guys.
Let me take a shot at this.
I don't do good deals.
I do great deals, okay?
[ laughs ]
and I make sure
they're great deals
so that both sides
make money.
I'll tell you
what your company's worth today,
and I'm right.
it's worth $2 million, okay?
You have to give up
25% equity, minimum,
for this 500k,
because you have to
jump this thing by 30%
to even make it something that a
major competitor will take out.
You have a lot of work
ahead of you,
and for that ride,
I'd want a new-risk premium --
50% of the business.
NARRATOR:
All five sharks are still in.
Kevin is interested
but believes the company
is highly overvalued.
You have a lot of work
ahead of you.
And for that ride,
I'd want a new-risk premium --
50% of the business.
I said I do great deals.
That would be a great deal.
That would make sense.
That'd be a great deal
for you.
[ laughter ]
you know, when
the devil looks at you,
he always says
it's a great deal, right?
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful.
But listen, I know you're
not gonna accept that offer,
so I'm not gonna make it,
and I'm out.
Here's where I'm at.
I'd love to be involved,
but there's got to be
a premium in it for me.
I mean, I think
there's a lot of risk,
so I'm gonna price-end
that risk for me.
I'll give you the $500,000
for 35%.
Appreciate the offer.
We do.
Which means you're taking
the offer?
Barbara, we want to hear
from you before we --
I have a partial offer.
I'm gonna give you
$250,000 for 20%,
but you're going to have to
get the other $250,000
from one other shark.
GREINER:
You know what?
I have to love
what I get into,
and I don't really
like pancakes...
So I'm out.
You know, I think
it's a good business,
but I just think you're
gonna have more challenges.
You've been on a nice ride.
You've executed incredibly well.
You're efficient.
You're great salespeople.
But I think you're gonna run
into some macro challenges.
I'm out.
Let me ask you a question
I don't think you considered.
I think it's worth
discussing now
'cause it's getting into
my interest range again.
I thought
you were out.
No, wait --
why do I always have to listen
to you all day long?
shut up.
Don't tell me to shut up.
Shut up.
I'm doing it right now.
If I wanted 2% share,
which is what
you're gonna get this year
if you're lucky
in this market,
could I buy it myself
for $5 million
without even
having you involved?
What, you're gonna go start
a pancake company in your house?
If I wanted to,
could I do it?
No, not you.
That's
so ridiculous!
Absolutely,
I could do it.
No way.
I could hire
a couple of guys,
go get a co-packer
to make this paste up,
and I could
buy myself
you know what?
that's ridiculous.
2% share of this market
easily for $2 million.
Let's
watch him do it.
That's
ridiculous.
I could buy
the shelf space.
No, you couldn't.
HERJAVEC:
You know what, guys?
I made you a decent offer.
Nobody else made you an offer.
GREINER:
Barbara did.
I did.
Excuse me.
She didn't make an offer
for the $500,000!
All right, I'll help her out.
I'll help her out.
I want -- for $250,000,
I want 25% of this business,
'cause I think I'm right
about what it's worth.
So what's the offer?
I'll join her. She's gonna
up her equity to 25%.
I feel greedy,
but I'll go along with him.
So now you have $500,000
from two sharks.
I want 25%
for my investment.
Means you're giving up
half the business,
'cause it's only worth
$2 million, guys.
I'm sorry.
HERJAVEC: So, guys, you got an
offer from Kevin and Barbara,
$500,000 for 50%, or an offer
of $500,000 for 35%.
What are you going to do?
Well, you guys,
thank you.
I mean, we do appreciate
the offers.
We appreciate
the interest.
But we feel the value's
way beyond what you've said.
We really do.
So we need to decline
the offers.
Seriously?
You're turning down $500,000?
Yeah, we're gonna
turn it down,
but we really, really
appreciate it. we really do.
I think
you guys are smart.
GREINER:
I do, too.
Good luck,
guys.
Good luck.
Appreciate it.
Thanks.
HERJAVEC:
Thank you.
O'LEARY:
All right, Robert,
get me the tranquilizer gun.
I'm taking the bear out.
[ laughter ]
GREINER: Run, bear.
Run, bear, run!
Even you couldn't put
a $5 million valuation on that.
There's no way that thing
was worth $5 million.
Yes, it was, easily.
They're buying every
square inch of shelf space.
All that has to happen is
the auntie has to go on deal
for a couple of months,
and they'll squeeze these guys
like teenage pimples.
You don't think that
the other bigger brands
have done discounts right next
to them in target and Costco?
Of course they have.
Total commodity, 100%.
With a bear.
Next.
Who cares?
NARRATOR:
Earlier this season,
we saw Melissa and Rick hinnant
make a deal with Barbara
for their fashion-sock company,
grace and lace.
You picked the smartest
person here. Good for you.
Let's see
how they're doing now.
Only five days after airing,
sales hit $1 million.
We couldn't
believe it.
And since we aired,
just three short months ago,
we've almost done
$3 million in sales.
MELISSA:
Before "Shark Tank," we had six
moms working out of our garage.
Since the show, we've moved into
a 3,000-square-foot facility
and now have over 36 people
working for grace and lace.
Hi, guys.
Hey, Barbara.
How are you?
Did you get the samples
out to Berkshire?
Yep.
Barbara has already
arranged a meeting
with the world's largest
manufacturer of knitted goods,
and through her contacts,
our products are gonna be
in the hands of people
at "vogue" and "bazaar"
and these amazing magazines
in New York City.
Bye-bye.
Back to work.
MELISSA: Walking into a store
and seeing grace and lace
almost brings me to tears.
I cannot believe
that this is my brand
sitting there being sold
on their tables.
Our dreams are coming true,
and really, it's all
because of "Shark Tank."
[ giggles ]
whoa!
whee!
When I look
at my kids now,
I see that we're creating
a legacy for them.
To know that your family's
future is more secure,
if not completely secure,
is such a good feeling.
Absolutely
a life changer.
Mwah.
NARRATOR:
Next into the tank are two moms
with a must-have accessory
for parents on the go.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Christie Barany.
I'm
Courtney Turich.
TOGETHER:
And we're the Monkey Mat Mamas.
We're seeking $100,000 in
exchange for 30% of our company.
Our product is the
award-winning Monkey Mat.
The Monkey Mat is the only
clean, portable surface
you can have
anywhere you go.
It's an innovative, new
essential for life on the go.
No bulky blankets
required.
So, the original inspiration
for the Monkey Mat
came during an unexpected
six-hour layover at the airport,
where I watched
my two beautiful girls
crawl and eat and play all over
those dirty, disgusting floors.
Ew.
Total cringe.
There has to be
a better way.
We searched for a solution
to meet our needs,
and when nothing existed,
we decided to create it.
There is nothing that provides
the portability, versatility,
and functionality with style
like the Monkey Mat.
The attached pouch
with easy buckle straps
secures onto anything --
cooler, stroller, bike handle,
purse, or diaper bag.
The custom fabric is soft,
durable, and water-repellant,
and grass, dirt, sand,
and messes shake right off.
The corners have weights
as well as loops
for additional grounding,
and in the center
of the mat,
there are loops for key
or toy attachments.
And, of course, it's
all machine-washable.
It comes in
four vibrant colors.
It is perfect
for outdoor concerts,
sporting events, picnics,
at the beach.
The response
has been fantastic,
but we need your help elevating
our business to the next level.
Can we see them?
Absolutely.
Courtney, I love the way
it folds back up.
Absolutely.
People are very amazed when
they see how quick and easy
it goes back
into the pouch.
GREINER: So, I have
to ask, are you related?
We get asked that a lot,
and we are not related.
However,
we're dear friends.
We've known each other
for 11 years.
Christie, well, do you
have sales today?
We do. We have $60,000 of sales
in our first year of business.
And how are you getting
those sales?
We are available
on our own website.
We have 51 retailers --
storefront retailers
and online businesses.
And we're also available in
three countries outside the U.S.
And what
does it cost?
$39.99.
Ooh! Wow.
Retail?
Retail.
Ouch. Ouch.
What is the cost to you?
What does it cost you to make
it, and where do you make it?
We actually make it
in China,
so with shipping and customs,
we're at $13.14.
Wow.
That sounds high.
That sounds really high.
Why?
What's in the material
that makes it cost so much?
It's a ripstop nylon,
but it's treated specially
to be both water-repellant
and also soft.
There's another material
that's embedded.
The weights are
stainless-steel disks.
The stainless-steel disks
are about 50 cents apiece,
so times four.
oh!
GREINER:
Which is a lot.
It is a lot.
It's very high.
And how many disks
are there?
Four, so there's one
in each corner.
I want you to help me
with something,
'cause I'm just
struggling a little bit, okay?
It's a piece of nylon
on the floor.
Why's anybody gonna pay
20, 30 bucks for this
when it's 2 bucks off a roll
in any clothing store?
You know what? At the end
of the day, Mr. Wonderful.
Yes.
If you can carry a yoga mat,
which people use it as,
a beach blanket,
a picnic blanket,
a baby blanket onto --
you can't stuff those
in your glove compartment,
you can't throw them in the
trunk of your car all together,
you can't --
it's a convenience item
more than a --
it is. definitely.
If you're
gonna plan --
absolutely.
Are you gonna pay
30 bucks for it?
I'm telling you, my wife,
in a heartbeat, would do it,
because it's for those
times you don't expect
something to happen.
Exactly.
Whether it's the airport,
or whether you're around...
Guys, I love the product.
I hate the price.
I think the price
has to be $9.99.
And he's right.
The higher-end-mom environment
are gonna buy it, right?
But that doesn't make it
a mass product.
Can you make it a mass product
with a $9.95 retail
that resembles anything that
has any of the quality at all?
I don't believe,
for that cost,
we would be able to provide
the quality of product
that we're looking to provide
with the versatility,
with the functionality.
Quality? It's a piece of cloth
on the floor in the airport!
Christie, I think it's
a very clever product,
but what I heard you say
today is,
from what you know today,
you can't get the price point
to have it become
a mass-market product.
I'm out.
Thank you very much.
You guys, with the right
strategic partner, you could.
Right.
Yes.
I mean, I know
because I manufacture
things made out of fabric.
I have for 17 years.
You think you can bring
this down?
Yes, I do.
I don't get it.
I just don't get it.
You know what,
Mr. Wonderful?
We have parents who use
this as a time-out mat.
We might have to put you
over in the corner.
I'd rather put it over top
of him, not underneath him.
That's a good idea,
too.
They use it as
fort covers, too.
Listen, somebody
figured out
how to make an umbrella
so inexpensive,
when it rains, I buy one
and I throw it out afterwards.
That's where
you need to go.
And maybe you'll get there,
but it won't be with me.
I'm out.
All right.
Thank you.
It's too small.
It should be larger.
The colors are off.
They're not hip.
And last, what you've heard
again and again,
it's way too expensive.
I think it's
a $10 product.
It should be priced exactly like
those cheap portable umbrellas
that come in a little kit.
that's it.
It's not for me.
I'm out.
Thanks
for your feedback.
I want you to do one thing
right now.
Sure.
Take it and fold it up
and put it back into the
zippered pouch for me.
Fold it or stuff it?
Well, I want to see
how hard it is.
I want to see how fast
you can do it.
Well, you
should do it.
They've been doing it
the whole time.
Look. Here's
the real test.
Yeah, Mark,
you do it.
[ laughter ]
it's a contest.
who's faster?
I cram.
TURICH: Yeah, exactly. Christie
has a rolling technique.
Mark's doing it the dad way --
just shove it in.
Yeah. No.
But it works
the same.
I feel like
a magician, right?
Oh, here I go!
I'm gonna --
wow.
he wins.
Whoo!
You beat me!
Hey, now. See?
See how easy it is?
Awesome.
Yeah, no,
it's actually --
well, if Mark
can do it...
You know, I want to see if,
Mark, you'll go in with me.
Okay.
We'll give you an offer
for the $100,000...
...35%.
I think between Mark and I
and our connections,
we can get this in.
I can help you
with the manufacturing
to get this way down.
And I could help you
with the online.
And he'll help you
And I'll help you with
all the different retailers.
What do you guys think?
100k for 35%.
Got to tell us
right now.
Yep.
You're one handshake away.
Let's do this.
Let's do the deal.
There you go.
Done.
We're not
monkeying around.
Thank you so much.
We're so excited.
Oh, well,
you're great.
Thank you, Lori.
It's gonna
be fabulous.
You covered everything.
I love that.
It's clever.
Thank you.
Whoo!
We did it!
[ laughs ]
way to go!
If you make your money back
on this within even five years,
six months.
Six months.
I will eat one of those mats.
I'll eat a mat.
GREINER: Yes, Mark.
That is not a magic carpet.
That is a ride to hell.
NARRATOR: Next up is a unique
alternative to delivered meals.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Nick Taranto.
And I'm Josh Hix.
And we're the founders
of Plated.
We're here today to ask you
for $500,000
in exchange for 4% equity in
our rapidly growing company.
[ laughter ]
at Plated, our mission is
to help Americans eat better.
Josh and I met
at Harvard business school.
After school, we both had
the same problem --
getting good food
on the table
was difficult, time-consuming,
and expensive.
We knew there had to be
a better way.
So we started Plated.
Plated delivers
all of the ingredients
in the exact portions
you need
to make a chef-designed,
delicious, nutritious meal
at home
in 30 minutes or less.
You come to the site,
pick out only exactly
what you want and how much,
and then we deliver
all of the ingredients,
along with recipe cards
and instructional videos
teaching you how to make
a delicious dish at home.
Since we launched
six months ago,
we've served tens of thousands
of meals around the Northeast.
Now we need you guys
to take us nationwide.
Sharks,
who's hungry?
GREINER: So, I want to see
if I understand this right.
I mean, I order
from a service.
They deliver right to my door
my groceries,
and all I have to do, then,
is just portion it out.
But then you still have to go
find the recipe.
You have to figure out
what you want to eat.
CUBAN: [ scoffs ]
If I'm using a recipe card --
recipe card, cookbook.
Six of one,
half dozen of the other.
We will take you from zero
to kitchen hero in 30 minutes.
Our customers tell us
that they love the experience
of getting everything
pre-portioned.
It's easy to make.
And the meal --
did you say it comes frozen?
All fresh.
GREINER:
And what does it cost?
Starts at
$10 per person.
You need to order
four portions.
So it's a
$40 minimum order.
Who pays shipping?
We do.
That's included
in the price.
GREINER: Is that sent overnight
with an ice pack in it?
You got it.
Same day
or overnight.
We have customers who
literally write in to us cold
and tell us that
twice a week,
they put the kids to bed, and
this is time with their spouse,
and it's a ritual, and it's
helping their relationship.
O'LEARY: But you don't need
to use your service to do that.
I'm very interested in
understanding the premium delta.
You don't,
but they are using it.
If I'm a family buying Lori's
way, or buying at the grocer's,
over the course of a year,
how much more is the family
paying to eat?
Yeah. So, here's where I think
you're going with that.
You know where I'm going
with it.
I have a lot of customers
that are grocery chains.
The margins are awful.
TARANTO: Here's the
dirty secret of grocery.
When you start out,
the gross margins are
actually pretty good --
somewhere between
40% and 50%.
But then you have spoilage
and overhead,
and that chews up
95% of the margin.
A grocery store throws away,
in some cases,
half of
the perishable food.
Plated delivers the amount
of spice you need
and not the $20 jar.
You get the amount
of basil you need
and not a giant thing
that will wilt.
Right, so you can make the
argument you're saving money
'cause you're not wasting.
We're throwing away less than
1% of what we order every week.
O'LEARY: Let's talk
about money for a second.
HERJAVEC: Well, Kevin,
can I just ask them?
They've been doing this
for how long?
Seven months.
Tell us about the actual numbers
you've had in seven months.
Our margins today
are 40%.
Right.
Those will go to 60%
at scale.
$350,000 in total sales,
but $100,000 of that
was the last month.
Tell me the projection
for the next six months.
Calendar year,
$2 1/2 million in sales.
Hmm.
And in the next 12 months, we'll
do about 10 million in sales.
Okay.
We project $1 million
a month in revenue
by the end of the year.
So, you're ramping up
every month?
We're growing at over 40%
each month.
Josh, how much cash did you have
to spend to start the business?
We each put in north
of $50,000 to start.
CUBAN: And then you
raised how much money?
To date,
about $3 million.
At what valuation?
Post-money --
$9 1/2 million.
Okay.
HERJAVEC:
Talk to me about expansion.
We'll have a half a dozen or so
hubs around the country.
We have two active now.
From our warehouse
in Brooklyn
and our warehouse
outside of Chicago,
we cover the entire Northeast
and the entire Midwest.
We're starting in San Francisco
in about four weeks.
You're shipping California
from Chicago?
Tell me about
your background.
I was doing tech
startups before.
Worked in finance for a bit,
and met Nick at business school.
Mm-hmm.
Josh is super-modest.
He's a great engineer
coming out of Georgia Tech.
Spent five years building
a software business.
I went to Dartmouth college
undergrad.
I did the joint degree
at the Kennedy school
and Harvard business school,
went to the Marine Corps
after hbs.
Wow.
Very impressive.
So I became the only person
to ever do that.
And how long were you
in the marines for?
You got to do more
with your lives. You
haven't done enough.
So, I did a year
of active duty.
I became
an infantry officer,
and now I'm still
in the reserves.
wow.
That's great.
O'LEARY:
Have you considered, once
you've captured that customer,
perhaps there comes a week
when they're so busy
that they need
the food prepared.
Totally. Know where
you're going with that,
and the different
product lines
are six months from now
coming out.
But there's a ton of
competition.
There is
a ton of competition.
Sure, but this is
about a brand, right?
We are building
an amazing brand.
We put a lot of time
into this.
Yeah, but...
HERJAVEC: You guys are
obviously really smart guys,
but, I mean, I can't
go along for the ride
unless I buy
into the concept.
what are you
doubting?
Personally,
I love to eat healthy,
but I wouldn't order something
that I have to cook.
Cooking is believing.
When people try this,
they come back.
This is a game-changer,
because it allows you
to have an experience
you would not have
otherwise.
All right, Josh, look,
you've had great answers.
I just can't get over
having to make it.
I can't invest in something that
I would not use on some level.
We'll send you
a free trial,
and we'd like to get
your feedback afterwards.
please do.
Send it to his wife.
She definitely wears
the pants in the family.
I've seen her.
[ laughter ]
my wife wouldn't use it,
and I wouldn't use it.
You know, for that reason,
I'm out.
O'LEARY:
The question is,
how much of a premium am I,
as an investor,
paying for the risk that this is
not proprietary anywhere?
I think I could do the whole
thing for 3 million bucks.
Instead, I have to pay
three times that multiple
to play with you.
Go find two hard chargers
who are smart, data-driven,
and are gonna knock it
out of the park
we'll beat you
to it.
Like the way we're gonna
knock it out of the park,
we will crush whoever
you bring on board.
I'm out.
GREINER:
You know what? I cook a lot.
The trouble I'm having
with this
is that if you're
somebody who cooks --
and I think most people
in America cook --
if you do, you don't
really need somebody
to send you in a box
the ingredients,
'cause you go
to the grocery store --
CORCORAN:
That's not their customer.
Wait, wait.
Yeah, it is,
though, Barb.
I was wondering
if it was more
urban-centered.
It is, though.
Think about it.
Like, instead of going
and ordering takeout
and eating that greasy
thing of Thai food --
but you still
have to cook it.
That's where I have
a little bit of difficulty.
I'm seeing it as
your customer is somebody
who's too busy to cook,
so for that reason, I'm out.
Who do you see as your
biggest competition right now
and your greatest threat?
Takeout.
Well,
that's pretty big.
Takeout is your enemy,
and that's a big one.
And you know what takeout
has over your concept?
You can decide tonight what
you're in the mood for eating
and get it to your table
and eat within the hour.
It's done.
So that is an obstacle.
This isn't for me.
I'm out.
Guys, I would not be
a customer.
That said, I don't have
to be a customer
for a lot of things
that I take interest in.
The real question is,
how do you preempt competition?
How do you make this
so that it's an actual company,
as opposed to
turning it into
a feature from any
of the high-end supermarkets?
So, to touch on that, the
back-end logistics are not easy.
Also, we're signing customers
up for yearlong contracts.
Okay, tell us
about that.
You can either buy just
LA carte, whenever you'd like,
or you can subscribe
and save.
And how many subscribers
do you have to that?
Several thousand.
Okay.
But this is another beauty of
the business, by the way.
We don't need a lot of customers
to make this a giant business.
Okay, so, guys,
I'll make you an offer.
I'm gonna offer you $500,000
at the $9 million valuation,
which is about 5.5%, 5.6%.
we'll figure that out.
And in addition,
I want advisory shares.
Whatever the best deal you give
to any of your other advisers --
that's what I want.
Do we have a deal?
TARANTO: So, you're
talking about 500k
at a 9 mil, at our...
yeah. you said
you left it open.
...What we were looking for,
at our valuation.
Yeah. Exactly.
Can we talk about it
real quick?
Why do you need to talk?
You basically told us
this is what you want,
so either you want
to do business --
we want you to be
a part of this, but we
need to just make sure
that our numbers
are working with...
I wouldn't
leave that room
with that kind of
a deal on the table.
...that we're on
the same page.
CUBAN: Seriously, though,
I mean, what am I missing here?
Because you said you wanted
advisory support.
Right.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know what
there is to talk about,
because I'm giving you
pretty much what you asked for.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'd be happy
with that.
Deal.
Let's do it.
All right.
Fantastic.
Appreciate it, guys.
I might even learn
how to pound meat.
Super excited.
Can we hug it out,
man?
Hug it out, baby.
[ both laugh ]
Thank you,
guys.
Pleasure.
Good job.
Thanks, guys.
All right, thanks,
Mark.
CUBAN:
See you guys. Thanks, guys.
Bye.
I'll take that.
Yeah, brother.
Hey, there was no doubt these
guys had a solid business, Mark.
There's no doubt
about that.
Yep. I mean, look,
there's risks,
as there are
to any business,
but in this
particular case,
the horse is a decent horse,
the jockeys are great jockeys.
And you might learn
to cook, Mark.
I'm not gonna learn
how to cook, ever.
[ laughs ]
I'm John.
I'm Sal.
I'm Anthony.
[ laughter ]
Sal and I
are cousins.
Me and Anthony,
best friends.
Put together,
we're like brothers.
How's my booboo?
Mwah.
We come from
New York City.
Rough neighborhood,
rough growing up for all of us.
We could have went the wrong way
very easily, but we didn't.
I work as a New York City
firefighter.
I've been on the job
for nine years now.
As a firefighter,
I have a lot of free time,
so to supplement my income,
I started a painting business.
Don't even think --
don't even think of rolling.
Stop.
Painting's
in our genes.
Long line of painters
right here.
Being painters, we always
had this one problem,
and one day, we just said,
"enough's enough."
together, we have developed
the most revolutionary product
the painting industry
has ever seen.
Boom.
Got it.
[ laughs ]
boom!
Running this business has been
a total team effort,
but I must say,
our backs are a little
against the ropes right now.
Striking a deal
with a shark
would just be an absolute
game-changer for us.
We're at that critical stage.
We're so close to making it.
Somebody like a shark
to push us over the edge
is really all we need.
Hi, sharks.
I'm Sal depaola.
I'm
John depaola.
Anthony Caputo.
Our company is called
liquid concepts,
creators of
the paint brush cover.
We're here today
seeking $50,000
for a 10% stake
in our company.
Sharks, the three of us
have been painting
for a very long
time.
In fact, together,
we have over 60 years
professional painting
experience.
Through the years, one thing
has bothered us most.
Every time we put down
our brush...
Oh, man.
Hey, come on.
Don't be silly. Listen.
Every time you put down
the brush, there's a problem.
Every time we put down the
brush, there was a problem.
Anyone who paints
can relate.
Whether you get a phone call,
you need to take a lunch break,
you have to pick up
the kids from school.
There has never been
a reasonable or convenient way
to keep your brush from drying
out or getting ruined until now.
Me and cousin Johnny --
Johnny boy over here
went to work in his lab --
A.K.A. his garage --
and developed
what has become
the most revolutionary
prototype...
Painting product
in the industry.
[ laughter, applause ]
Sal, you did
a great job!
You did it!
Slow down. Slow down.
It's not like we invented a
robot that's gonna paint for us.
We did, however, revolutionize
the painting industry
with one piece of plastic.
Introducing the
paint brush cover.
You sharks might be thinking
you've seen this before.
You sharks haven't.
In fact, maybe you're thinking,
why didn't you think of it?
We got you covered.
we thought of it.
CAPUTO:
The days of plastic wrap
and other makeshift
coverings are over.
With the paint brush cover's
unique, airtight design,
it allows you to store
your wet brush for days, weeks,
even months without
that wet brush drying out,
saving anyone who paints a lot
of time and a lot of money.
Johnny, hang on
a sec.
Are you telling me all I have
to do is put my brush in there
and it doesn't dry up?
That's it.
Never dries out.
Not only does it not dry out,
but we've tested it
for as long as three months.
Really?
It stays wet.
In fact, we have one here
that's been through the mill,
and it's still wet.
I find it hard to believe
that this little plastic cover
keeps the paintbrush for days.
Well, it holds almost
100% humidity inside of there.
Picture tupperware.
If I was to take paint
out of a can
and put it into tupperware
and close it,
you could put it on the shelf,
come back to it, open it up.
It's not gonna be dry.
It's gonna be wet.
It's such a great idea.
If it's such a great idea,
how many have you sold?
We've sold 17,000.
Wow.
And how many dollars
is that?
$35,000.
50% of that revenue
has come in over the course
of the past three months.
How much does it cost you
to make it right now?
41 cents a unit.
And you sell it for $2?
Correct.
And to a retailer
for 2 bucks.
What do they sell it for?
$3.99.
$3.99 target price.
How do you sell them?
To who?
We started off, obviously,
just door to door.
Old-fashioned.
Come on.
And nobody said no.
We went to three stores
this morning.
this morning. It's true.
Did you sell any?
Every store.
Have you tried to sell
to Lowe's or Home Depot
or one of the Lar--
we're talking to Walmart
right now.
We have distributors in six
different countries right now.
So, you're saying
that there's nothing else
out there like this?
No.
Not an
airtight one.
How is that possible?
That's what we were saying!
I've been thinking --
how could no one
have thought of this?
None of you sound that smart.
Who thought of it?
[ laughter ]
which one's Moe,
which one's Larry,
which one's curly, right?
Listen, we've both
been painting.
We're tired of wrapping
in wrap.
Yeah, but who said,
"I have an idea"?
He did.
I've been thinking of this
for about 10 years.
I knew it, and you're
the best-looking one,
too. You got both.
[ laughter ]
What are you guys
gonna use the money for?
Number one is
to restock inventory.
We have letters of intent
into the hundreds
of thousands of units.
Bunnings happens to be
the Home Depot of Australia.
We're in talks right now
with a buyer for bunnings who
wanted a quote for 250 pallets.
What's that in total dollars?
It was about
$450,000.
Okay, so that raises
a big red flag, guys.
Why did you only ask
for $50,000,
knowing that
you might have a sale
that would require you
to put up a lot of cash?
Because we feel confident
enough in our company
where we don't want to give up
that much equity.
but we feel --
that's smart. that's smart.
equity is very expensive,
particularly
if you have a winner.
You know he's gonna
offer you a royalty deal.
I'll tell you what I'll do
with you guys, all right?
Yeah,
there we go.
I like what you're doing.
I like the product.
I'll give you $50,000 for 10%
royalty on all of your sales,
and I think you're gonna need
more money, guys.
I really do.
So you'll
offer us more.
Yeah, well, I'm gonna start
with what you asked for.
I'll give you
$50,000 for 10%,
then I'm gonna help you raise
what you're going to need
to fund this inventory.
And I would help you
get into retail.
I think this is
a very interesting story.
Thank you.
So, Johnny, I'm curious to see
what you think
about the royalty thing.
yeah.
I like it,
and I respect it.
CORCORAN:
Smart guy.
I mean, with that
being said --
you're open
to other offers.
I'm open
We're
open-minded.
And you guys got to give me
a little more space,
'cause I keep hitting
my shoulders.
You know,
I need my space.
All right.
You're saying the company's
worth $500,000.
Correct.
I'll give you the $50,000
for 20%.
That's much more expensive
than a royalty.
Way more expensive.
You started at somewhere.
I'm starting somewhere.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
Kevin, in regards
to your royalty,
what will you focus
on our business
to help us move forward?
O'LEARY: You know, the great
thing about a royalty deal
is it incentivizes us
and aligns it together,
because the only thing
I want is sales.
So, for me,
what I would be doing
is focusing on big-box partners
and getting it in the store.
So I only make money
if we sell the product.
Even if they're not
profitable sales.
Right.
But you can decide whether
to take the sale or not.
I can bring the buyer
to you very easily.
And if he doesn't bring
any sales --
he's not invested in
the success of the company.
Listen, talk is cheap.
Money talks.
That's what matters.
You understand
exactly what I'm saying.
We know that.
If they can come up
with a better structure --
but when you start
giving away equity,
in the long run,
that's incredibly expensive.
We understand that.
I personally would
just love to know
that you're invested
in the company as well.
All right, I'll make it
more interesting for you.
I'll give you $100,000.
I'll leave my royalty in place,
but I want 5% equity.
That aligns us even further.
I do everything in my power
to get us more sales.
I get my 10%
every time a unit's sold.
That's about 20 cents.
That's how I start
to recoup my capital.
What do you want to do?
GREINER:
Wait a minute.
I'm going to make you
an offer.
NARRATOR: Sal, John,
and Anthony have two offers.
Robert has offered $50,000
for 20% equity.
Kevin has offered $100,000
for 5% equity,
plus a royalty of 10%.
But Lori is also interested.
What do you want to do?
GREINER:
Wait a minute.
I'm going to make you
an offer.
I'll give you $100,000
at 20%,
plus, if you just
take the deal right now,
I'll add another $100,000
that will go towards
paying for the first
purchase orders
if we need excess money,
'cause we're gonna be
out there so fast.
So, Lori, is that your offer --
$200,000 for 20%?
It's an offer in front
of you right now.
If you take it
right now.
And you're gonna do everything
in your power to get us on QVC.
Oh, you know it.
QVC, Walmart.
Get us and -- picking up
the phone and be saying,
"hey, you know what?
"Walmart, listen,
these are our guys.
This is it."
Lowe's, menards, Home Depot --
everywhere, lightning speed.
And I have another offer.
I'm gonna give you $100,000 --
guys, if you listen
to this offer,
there's an expiration date
on that extra $100,000.
I don't know if you heard me say
my offer's a better offer,
and you haven't heard
from Cuban either.
I would listen.
I wouldn't listen.
You'll wonder the rest of your
life what you turned away.
You guys know what I can do.
You've studied all of us.
You know what each one of us
brings to the table.
I guarantee you my
offer's better than that.
It's a no-lose situation.
I love you guys, and I will put
my heart and soul into this.
My offer is that you have
to take it now, though.
And you haven't heard
our two offers yet.
We know
what we want to do.
We know.
Go get it.
All right.
Lori, welcome
to the family.
[ gasps ]
Yay!
Ah, crap.
What?!
Sorry, Barbara.
JOHN:
No offense, Barbara.
That is great.
"sorry, Barbara"!
You're breaking my heart!
This is awesome.
There you go.
You guys are great.
Sorry.
You should have listened.
Isn't that awesome?
JOHN:
All right, boys.
[ laughs ]
We did it.
Yeah, baby.
You know what?
They're not so smart.
I was offering them $300,000
with a $500,000 credit.
Well, they were smart.
They took mine.
No, they weren't smart.
They short-sold themselves.
Yeah, they were.
I scooped you.
I'm really pissed,
Lori.
We're not making enough noise.
Come on.
Whoo!
Whoo.
CAPUTO: Making a deal
with Lori's like
being up in the bottom
of the ninth
and hitting a grand slam
to win the World Series.
This was a total home run
for us.